>>> WHAT'S GOING ON EVERYBODY.
IAN HARTITZ HERE ON BEHALF OF
PFF.
WE HAVE A FANTASTIC SHOW ON THE
WAY FOR YOU GUYS TODAY.
THE WEEK 17 CHAMPIONSHIP WEEK.
IS GOING TO WIN SOME FANTASY
FOOTBALL HARDWARE.
WHY THE HECK NOT.
I JUST WANT TO UPDATE YOU GUYS
ON A FEW INJURIES THAT WE DO
HAVE GOING AROUND THE LEAGUE.
DERRICK HENRY HAS BEEN RULED
OUT , AND LISA REPORTERS HAVE
TOLD US HE'S GOING TO BE OUT AS
HE WAS LISTED AS DOUBTFUL.
NOMINAL BACKUP, SO REPORTEDLY
PER THE NFL NETWORK, IS GOING
TO BE HASSAN HASKINS, THE
ROOKIE FROM MICHIGAN, WHO
UNFORTUNATELY TORE MANY OHIO
STATE BUCKEYE FANS HEARTS OUT
LAST NOVEMBER, BUT HE COULD BE
THE SAVING GRACE FOR YOUR
FANTASY SEASON.
I WOULDN'T GET CARRIED AWAY.
THIS IS AN OFFENSE AND PLAY FOR
14 TO 15 POINTS.
NOT THE BEST OFFENSIVE
ENVIRONMENTS, BUT YOU COULD DO
WORSE THAN 15 TO 20 TOUCHES.
IF YOU ARE ONE OF THE MANAGERS
WITHOUT DERRICK HENRY OR TONY
POLLARD, YOU COULD DO WORSE
THAN PICKING UP HASKINS.
SPEAKING OF TONY POLLARD, HE'S
NOT EXPECTED  TO SUIT UP.
I APPRECIATE YOU HAVING OUR
FANTASY MANAGERS AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THOUGHT.
IT REALLY DOES BRING UP THE
POSSIBILITY TO SEE EZEKIEL
ELLIOTT WITH A FULL-TIME ROLE,
SOMETHING THAT THE COWBOYS HAVE
BEEN MORE WILLING TO GIVE THEM
IN PAST YEARS.
THEY'VE TURNED THE BACKFIELD
RIGHTFULLY INTO MORE OF A 50-50
SPLIT.
YES TENNESSEE TITANS RUN
DEFENSE IS AN AWFULLY GREAT
UNIT.
THEY REALLY DO JUST FORCE TEAMS
TO HAVE TO GO IN THE AIR
BECAUSE OF HOW SOUND THEY ARE
AGAINST THE RUN, BUT WITH NO
POLLARD ABOUT THAT SWEET VOLUME
AND TOUCHDOWN UPSIDE IN THE
COWBOYS OFFENSE THAT LEADS THE
NFL IN POINTS PER GAME SINCE
DAK PRESCOTT GOT BACK FROM
INJURY, EZEKIEL ELLIOTT IS IN
THE RB ONE DISCUSSION.
THAT EVERYONE, WELCOME TO BE
OUR FANTASY LIFE PRESENTED BY
STATE FARM.
AS I SAID A FEW MINUTES AGO, WE
HAVE A FANTASTIC SHOW ON THE
DOCKET FOR YOU.
I LOVE SEEING ALL OF YOU GUYS
IN THE CHANNEL BETTY.
I WANT TO ANSWER AS MANY OF
YOUR QUESTIONS AS A CANTOR AT
THE SHOW.
FIRST OF ALL, I TRY TO GET
THROUGH A BUNCH OF THESE GUYS
THAT WE DO THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
I'M NOT TELLING YOU GUYS START
THIS TOP FIVE RUNNING BACK NO
MATTER WHAT, TRYING TO GO OUT
ON A LIMB JUST A LITTLE BIT AND
TALK THROUGH SOME OF THE GUYS
THAT MAYBE YOU ARE A BIT MORE
UNCERTAIN ABOUT.
WE WILL KICK THINGS OFF WITH A
LOOK AT THE LATEST OF ALL TIME
HIMSELF, BUT I'M SORRY MR. TOM
BRADY.
YOU ARE RECOMMENDED TO SIT THIS
WEEK.
WE HAVE SEEN THE BRADY AND THE
BUCCANEERS GET BACK ON TRACK TO
A SLIGHT EXTENT, BUT EVEN THEN,
28th IN SCORING THIS YEAR.
28, TOM BRADY, AND THE
BUCCANEERS, DESPITE HAVING A
FAIRLY HEALTHY GROUP OF
WEAPONS.
MIKE EVANS HAS BEEN THERE,
LENNY FOURNETTE PLAYING THROUGH
THE PAIN.
I KNOW LOSING GROUND, I DIDN'T
EXPECT THEM TO REPEAT,  BUT
28th IS JUST A FOUL THAT I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY SAW COMING.
BRADY AT THIS POINT IS NOT
SOMEONE WE CAN TRUST IN THE
OFFENSE.
AND HONESTLY THE ONLY GUYS THAT
WE CAN, WE YOU TAKE AWAY ROB
GRONKOWSKI AND YOU HAVE MIKE
EVANS ALL OF A SUDDEN ALLERGIC
TO THE END ZONE, 11 STRAIGHT
GAMES WITHOUT A TOUCHDOWN FOR
MIKE EVANS.
2020, 2021, INCLUDING PLAYOFFS,
HE NEVER WENT MORE THAN TWO
GAMES WITHOUT SCORING A
TOUCHDOWN.
WITH ALL THIS SAID, TOM BRADY
IS MY QB 14 FOR THE WEEK.
AS I SAID BEFORE, LOVE ALL OF
YOU GUYS HANGING OUT WITH US IN
THE CHAT FROM W LVS THIS
EVENING.
WE LOST TONY POLLARD.
SHOULD I GO WITH MOSS OR
ROBINSON?
WITH BRIAN ROBINSON WE COULD
SEE ANTONIO GIBSON NOW IN THE
PITCHER.
IN THAT CASE IT WOULD BUMP THEM
UP ENOUGH TO HAVE HIM AS THE
PREFERRED PICK OVER ZACH MAAS.
OTHERWISE GO AHEAD AND GIVE ME
MOUSE.
WE'VE SEEN HIM PLAY OVER 70% OF
THE SNAPS , AND IT WAS
IMPORTANT LAST WEEK BECAUSE IT
ALSO INCLUDED JORDAN WILKINS
BEING ACTIVE.
GIVE ME BRIAN ROBINSON,
OTHERWISE ZACH MAAS.
FROM MR. PANGAEA, NEED A SECOND
QUARTERBACKS, STIDHAM OR TEDDY
BRIDGEWATER.
NEVER JARED STIDHAM.
THAT IS THE ANSWER TO THAT ONE.
IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, TEDDY
BRIDGEWATER, HE KNOWS HOW TO
COVER SPREADS.
HE'S BEEN A DECENT FANTASY QB
OVER THE YEARS WHEN SURROUNDED
WITH HIGH-QUALITY WEAPONS LIKE
HE IS RIGHT NOW WITH TYREEK
HILL AND JAYLEN WADDLE.
GIVE ME TEDDY.
GOOD LUCK MY FRIEND.
LET'S GET TO A POSITIVE THING,
START AT THE QUARTERBACK
POSITION.
MINSHEW MANIA HIMSELF, GARDNER
MINSHEW, QB ONE PROBABLY FOR
ANOTHER WEEK.
WE DID GET JALEN HURTS BACK AT
PRACTICE TODAY IN A LIMITED
CAPACITY, BUT JUDGING FROM SOME
OF THE REPORTS, HE WASN'T
PARTICIPATING IN SOME OF THAT
DRILLS WERE THEY ARE TRYING TO
KNOCK OUT THE FUMBLE AND ALL OF
THAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY ARE BEING
CAREFUL WITH JALEN HURTS.
AS MUCH AS IT IS NICE CEILING
HIM BACK AT PRACTICE, MOST
RECENT REPORTS HAVE INDICATED
IS GOING TO BE UNTIL THE
PLAYOFFS.
WITH MINSHEW NOW, THREE PARTS
OF THE LAST TWO SEASONS, AND
HE'S RIPPED UP TWO TOP 10
FANTASY FINISHES, AND WHY NOT.
COULD YOU PICK A BETTER OFFENSE
IN THE NFL IN TERMS OF JUST
OVER ALL SURROUNDING SUPPORTING
CAST?
I CANNOT.
HONESTLY THE ANALYTICS TELL US
THAT IS THE CASE.
I TOOK EVERY SINGLE TEAMS PFF
RUSHING, RECEIVING, PASS
BLOCKING, AND RUN BLOCKING.
BASICALLY EVERYTHING EXCEPT
PASSING WHICH IS CONTROLLED BY
THE QUARTERBACK, NOBODY HAS
BEEN BETTER THAN THE
PHILADELPHIA EAGLES THIS SEASON
IN TERMS OF THAT SURROUNDING
CAST.
A.J.
BROWN, DEVAUNTE SIGLER, A
HEALTHY DALLAS GODDARD.
OF EVENT GAME THAT'S FEATURING
A BETTER VERSION OF SANDERS.
AHEAD OF GUYS LIKE AARON
RODGERS, MIKE WAITE, KIRK
COUSINS, AND MORE.
MAN I HOPE THAT HEAD IS FEELING
BETTER.
IS DATSUN A MUST START?
I WOULDN'T SAY I MUST START.
WE HAVE CARSON WENTZ, IT DOES
CHANGE THE DYNAMIC OF THIS
WASHINGTON COMMANDER'S OFFENSE.
CURTIS SAMUEL HAD I BELIEVE 10
ADDITIONAL TARGETS THAN TERRY
McLAURIN DURING THAT STRETCH.
I'M NOT SAYING HE'S A GREAT
DECISION MAKER WITH THE
FOOTBALL IN HIS HANDS OR
ANYTHING, BUT NOBODY IS WORTH
THEN TAYLOR HEINICKE HE.
MUCH MORE OF A GUNSLINGER
MINDSET.
I EQUATE TAYLOR HEINICKE HE TO
PATRICK MAHOMES WANTS TO PLAY
EVERY SINGLE GAME LEFT-HANDED.
HE DOESN'T MAKE THE WRONG READ
A LOT OF TIMES, BUT I DON'T
THINK HE HAS THE ARM STRENGTH
TO LIVE UP TO WHAT HIS BRAIN IS
ALWAYS TRYING TO DO.
I THINK CURTIS SAMUEL ACTUALLY
LEAVES HIM TO BE THE NUMBER TWO
WIDE RECEIVER FIND TERRY
McLAURIN.
DATSUN DOESN'T NEED TO BE A
MUST START UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES.
FINALLY JULIE AND I GOT, GABE
DAVIS OR JOHN GODSON.
I'M GOING TO GO WITH GABRIEL
HERE.
IT'S BEEN AN UP-AND-DOWN SEASON
WITH MORE BUSTS AND BROOMS.
AS THE NUMBER TWO RECEIVER IN A
JOSH ALLEN LED OFFENSE, WE
WOULD HOPE FOR A BIGGER OVERALL
COUNTING STATS, BUT THERE IF
THERE WAS A GAME TO SEE THINK
THAT GABRIEL DAVIS WITH OTHER
COMPLEMENTARY SEASON RECEIVERS
AND BUBBLE OF, AN ABSOLUTE
SHOULD ON A MONDAY NIGHT
FOOTBALL AGAINST JOE BURROW AND
THE CINCINNATI BENGALS.
GABE DAVIS AND JAHAN DOTSON.
GIVE ME THE GUY CATCHING BALLS
HIM A JOSH ALLEN IN THE OVERALL
MORE HIGH-SCORING MATCHUP.
MOVING ON TO SOME RUNNING BACKS
NOW.
HASN'T BEEN THE GREATEST
STRETCH RUN HERE.
THE USAGE IS STILL THERE.
I'M CONFIDENT WE CAN GET THAT
BOOM WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR.
TRAVIS, THE JAGUARS SECOND YEAR
RUNNING BACK.
UNFORTUNATELY HE WAS ROBBED OF
HIS ROOKIE SEASON WITH THAT
FOOT INJURY.
WITH HIM COMING BACK FROM
ANOTHER FOOT INJURY HE SUFFERED
THIS YEAR, FOR STRAIGHT GAMES
WITH 70% TOUCHES.
THEY'VE BEEN VERY MUCH DOWN TO
FEED HIM THE BALL.
IN THOSE PERFORMANCES, 16, 17,
21, AND 25 TOUCHES IN THIS
GAME.
IT WOULD BE COOLER IF THEY
THREW THE BALL MORE, BUT IT'S
TOUGH TO COMPLAIN ABOUT THAT
SORT OF VOLUME, ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE HAVE A COMING UP NOW AGAINST
THE HOUSTON TEXANS, LEAGUE'S
WORST DEFENSE PAIRED WITH
ANTENNA AND THE REST OF THE
JAGUARS STARTERS FOR THAT
MATTER, YOU DO HAVE TO BE
SOMEWHAT CONCERNED ABOUT IF
THEY ARE STILL GOING TO BE
GOING FULL SPEED THIS WEEK
BECAUSE AS WE KNOW REALLY THIS
AFC SOUTH IS COMING DOWN TO
TITANS JAGUARS IN WEEK 18.
NOT AS MUCH OF ANYTHING TO PLAY
FOR THIS WEEK.
LUCKILY OUR GUY DOUG PETERSON
HAS ALREADY COME OUT IN THE
PRESS CONFERENCE AND SAID HE
HAS ABSOLUTELY NO INTENTIONS OF
RESTING ANY OF THESE GUYS.
WE'VE SEEN THE USAGE.
WE KNOW ETIENNE.
A LUNCHEON WITH THE BALL  IN
HIS HANDS.
HE HAS A FULL-TIME POWER UP.
I WOULD SAY A FULL-TIME GOLDEN
MUSHROOM GOING BACK TO OUR
MARIO KART DAYS.
THE DUDE IS ABSOLUTELY ELECTRIC
OUT THERE.
HE IS MY RB 13 ON THE WEEK
AHEAD OF GUYS LIKE KENNETH
WALKER, CAM AKERS, LEONARD
FOURNETTE ,  WHO I JUST DON'T
THINK HAVE AS GOOD OF A
MATCHUP, AND WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT SIMILAR IF NOT BETTER
VOLUME FOR A GUY LIKE TRAVIS
ETIENNE.
KEEP IT COMING IN THE CHAT.
I APPRECIATE YOU EACH AND EVERY
WEEK HERE ON BR FANTASY LIVE.
BROCK PURDY OR GARDNER MINSHEW.
I'M GOING TO BE ROLLING WITH
MINSHEW HERE.
THE THING WITH BROCK PURDY.
I BELIEVE HE HAS 11 CARRIES FOR
19 YARDS, SOMETHING HORRIFIC.
HE IS AN ABSOLUTE ZERO IN THE
RUN GAME, AND WHATEVER.
THEY HAVE CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY
AND GEORGE KITTLE, PLENTY OF
GUYS THEY CAN GET THE BALL TO
AND NOT RELY ON BROCK PURDY'S
WHEELS.
WITH MINSHEW, I THINK THE
PASSING NUMBERS ARE IN A
SITUATION  WHERE WE CAN SAY
MAYBE THOSE ARE PRETTY EQUAL TO
GUYS IN OFFENSES WHERE, AGAIN,
PLACES TO GO ALL OVER THE PLACE
WITH THE FOOTBALL.
WHEN YOU DO HAVE MINSHEW, AND
THE BIGGEST LESSON IN THE NFL
THIS SEASON, AND THAT BEING THE
PHILADELPHIA EAGLES QB SNEAKS,
FINDING PAYDIRT ON THE GROUND,
GIVE ME MINSHEW OVER PURDY BY A
FEW SPOTS.
A GOOD PROBLEM TO HAVE.
FROM EMPANADAS FOR LIFE,  BREAK
GREAT NAMES TONIGHT, ABSOLUTELY
NOT.
IF YOU ARE REALLY DESPERATE, WE
ARE TALKING 14 TEAM LEAD, THREE
FLEXES, AND IT'S BETWEEN HIM
AND TUTU ATWELL, THEN MAYBE
MALIK DAVIS WITH TONY POLLARD
NOT EXPECTED TO PLAY.
MORE THAN ANYTHING, EZEKIEL
ELLIOTT, BEING HEALTHY.
LET'S REMEMBER HE'S PLAYED A
GOOD SIX OR SEVEN GAMES HAVE
SENT ORIGINALLY SUFFERING THAT
INJURY.
BEING HEALTHY AND STILL IN THE
GOOD GRACES OF THE COWBOYS.
OBVIOUSLY TONY POLLARD HAS HAD
A FANTASTIC SEASON IN HIS OWN
RIGHT, BUT EZEKIEL HAS BEEN
PRETTY DARN GOOD AS WELL.
HE HAS NOT FINISHED OUTSIDE OF
THE TOP 20 WEEKLY RUNNING BACKS
SINCE WEEK FIVE.
I REALLY THINK WE COULD SEE A
SITUATION WHERE UNLESS THE
COWBOYS COMPLETELY BLOW OUT THE
TITANS, IT'S POSSIBLE.
I DON'T THINK MALIK IS GETTING
MORE THAN 3 TO 5 TOUCHES IN
THIS ONE.
ALL RIGHT, ANOTHER RUNNING BACK
THAT WE ARE FEELING GOOD ABOUT,
AND WE WILL BE RECOMMENDING
THEM AS A START, FALCONS NEW RB
ONE, TYLER ALGER.
THIS PAINS ME GUYS.
IF YOU GO TO MY TWITTER, I'VE
BEEN A LONGTIME PRESIDENT OF
THE CORDERO PATTERSON FAN CLUB.
BEST KICKER OF ALL TIME MY BUTT
WITH ALGER, HE'S BEEN AWESOME
IN HIS OWN RIGHT.
IS ONE OF THE MOST EFFICIENT
RUNNING BACKS.
100 PLUS CARRIES WITH THE
WE HAVE SEVEN THIN PFF RUSSIAN
GRADE. TIED IN SEVENTH, TIED
FOR FIFTH AND MISSED TACKLE FOR
CARRIES.
THEY DON'T THROW THE BALL TOO
MUCH TO ANYONE IN ATLANTA, BUT
THAT BEING SAID WE NOW HAVE THE
BELL COUNT BACK WITH A NICE
USAGE CHANGE IN WEEK 16, REALLY
TURNING OVER THE BACKFIELD TO
HIM IN A MATTER BECAUSE THE
CARDINALS WHERE IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT,  30th -RANKED
DEFENSE AND SCORING ON THE
SEASON.
ALLGEIER IS MY RB 18 AHEAD OF
GUYS LIKE CAMARA.
FROM TIER THE GOD SWIFT DJ
MOORE OR AJ DYLAN.
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO GO WITH AJ
DYLAN IN THAT CONVERSATION.
THE WHOLE ERIN JONES THINGS HAS
BEEN VERY TOUGH TO GET A READ
ON.
LAST WEEK HE SET SEASON LOW
MARKS IN TOUCHES AND SNAP
RATES, AT LEAST COMPARED TO HIS
OTHER GAMES WERE HE WASN'T
ACTIVELY INJURED, BUT WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT ACTIVELY INJURED
MEANS ANYMORE FOR HIM AND GREEN
BAY.
ONE ISSUE AFTER ANOTHER FOR
JONES, AND IN THE SEARCH
THEY'VE BEEN MORE WILLING THAN
EVER TO JUST TURN THE BACKFIELD
MORE AND MORE OVER TO AJ DYLAN.
HE HAS OUTSCORED AARON JONES
TWO TIMES OF THE LAST FOUR
WEEKS.
DJ MOORE HAS BEEN FIGHTING THE
END ZONE IN THREE OF HIS LAST
FOUR GAMES, BUT ACTUALLY
AVERAGING FEWER TARGETS PER
GAME THAN HE WAS WITH BAKER AND
P.J.
WALKER.
JUST NOT ENOUGH VOLUME.
GIVE ME AJ DYLAN.
AND WHAT YOU THINK OF HERBERT
THIS WEEK?
KHALIL HERBERT I HAVE NO
INTEREST OF PLAYING.
I DIDN'T SEE ENOUGH USES BEHIND
DAVID MONTGOMERY.
YOU ARE PROBABLY TECH MET
JUSTIN HERBERT.
IN THAT CASE YOU ARE LOOKING AT
SOMEONE WHO CONTINUES TO MAKE
GREAT PLACE AS LONG AS HE HAS
ALL OF HIS PLAYMAKERS HEALTHY,
WHICH AT THIS POINT IN THE
SEASON THEY DO.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER WHEN WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT JUSTIN
HERBERT, HE SUFFERED THAT RIB
INJURY IN WEEK TWO OR THREE.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT IS EASY TO
PLAY THROUGH.
ACCORDINGLY WE HAVEN'T SEEN HIM
GIVE US, LOVE, NOT LIKE JUSTIN
HERBERT WAS GOING TO BE PUTTING
UP JUSTIN FIELDS OR LAMAR
JACKSON RUSHING YARDS, BUT MORE
OF A ZERO THEN WE COULD
REMEMBER.
JUSTIN HERBERT OR ME IS MY QB
FIVE IN THIS SPOT.
ONLY GUYS I WOULD START AHEAD
OF THEM IS JOE BURROW, JUSTIN
FIELDS, JOSH ALLEN, AND PATRICK
MAHOMES.
KICK RETURNS, DEVON HESSLER IS
THE KING PUNT RETURNER.
HE HAS THE RECORD FOR RETURN
TOUCHDOWNS.
DON'T SHOOT THE MESSENGER.
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE FAN
CLUB.
YES, DEVIN HESTER A KING IN HIS
OWN RIGHT.
I DO HAVE A SIT HERE AND IS
GOING TO BE SOMEONE THAT I DO
THINK IS PLAYING BETTER AS THE
SEASON GOES ON, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE AREN'T GETTING
THE VOLUME WE NEED TO RECOMMEND
HIM AS A START.
THE BALTIMORE RAVENS RUNNING
BACK JK DOBBINS.
THE TROUBLING THING WITH
DOBBINS AS THEY WENT AHEAD AND
ASKED HIS HEAD COACH JOHN
HARBAUGH WHAT HE ACTUALLY
THINKS ABOUT DOBBINS AND GUS
EDWARDS.
ARE THEY STILL BEING LIMITED BY
THESE INJURIES, AND THE ANSWER
WAS NO THEY ARE NOT.
THIS IS WHAT THE RAVENS AND
GREAT ROMAN WANT TO DO.
THREE DIFFERENT RUNNING BACKS.
NOT SO MUCH DRAKE IN RECENT
WEEKS, BUT THOSE GUYS HAVE
MATTERED ULTIMATELY IN THESE
THREE GAMES BACK WITH BOTH
EDWARDS AND DOBBINS IN THE
PITCHER.
WE'VE ACTUALLY SEEN  THEM OUT
TARGET THOSE TWO 2-1. WITH
DOBBINS IT'S ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT YOU ARE RELYING ON
HIM TO MAKE THE MOST OF 12 TO
15 TOUCHES PER GAME THAT WILL
ALL BE ON THE GROUND.
IT'S AN OFFENSE WITHOUT THE
SAME SORT OF SCORING UPSIDE
WITH LAMAR JACKSON NOT LOOKING
LIKELY TO RETURN THIS WEEK.
AGAIN WITH DOBBINS THESE THREE
GAMES BACK, 15, 14, 12 TOUCHES.
43%, 38 PERCENT, 42%.
IT'S WHAT THEY USED TO DO
BEFORE HE SUFFERED THE INJURY
IN 2021.
UNFORTUNATELY HE IS NOT
AVERAGING THE SIX YARDS PER
CARRY THAT HE DID BACK IN 2020
TO MAKE THINGS A BIT EASIER.
JK DOBBINS, DON'T HATE THE
PLAYER, HATE HIS USAGE.
IS JUST THE RB 25 ON THE WEEK
FOR ME BEHIND GUYS LIKE NAJI
HARRIS, MILES SANDERS, BOTH
PACKERS RUNNING BACKS.
I ALSO WANT TO QUICKLY GO
THROUGH ANOTHER RUNNING BACK
POSITION, SOMEONE THAT GAVE US
WITH A GOOD WEEKS WITHIN THE
LAST MONTH OR TWO, BUT I THINK
WE'VE SEEN THIS BACKFIELD GO
OVER MORE SO TO THE TEAMS WEEK
ONE STARTER AND EARLY-SEASON
REQUIRES, AND THAT WILL BE FOR
SHOD WHITE OF THE TAMPA BAY
BUCCANEERS.
A LOT OF THE THINGS I SAID
ABOUT TOM BRADY AND THE OVERALL
OFFENSIVE ENVIRONMENT APPLY
HERE.
28th AND SCORING.
WE AREN'T GETTING A TEAM THAT'S
GOING TO BE GIVING US A BUNCH
OF EX-PAT ACCESS BOOM GAMES
WITH POINTS FLYING ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
ONE TIME ALL SEASON THIS
OFFENSE HAS SCORED MORE THAN 23
POINTS IN A GAME.
TRULY JUST A MADDENING
SITUATION.
AND FOR BYRON TO COME OUT A FEW
WEEKS AGO SAYING WE AREN'T
PLAYING FANTASY FOOTBALL, WE
ARE WORRIED ABOUT REAL LIFE.
THAT'S AN INSULT.
WHEN ARTHUR SMITH SAID THAT
EARLIER IN THE YEAR, AT LEAST
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT A TOP 10
SCORING OFFENSE AND WINNING
GAMES AND PUTTING UP OVER 30
POINTS AND AFTERWARDS WHEN
PEOPLE WERE ASKING ABOUT KYLE
PITTS USAGE, IT'S LIKE WHO
CARES, WE ARE SCORING POINTS
AND WINNING GAMES.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT FANTASY
FOOTBALL.
THAT I GET, BUT FOR BYRON TO
STEAL HIS FLOW, IT DIDN'T MAKE
SENSE FOR HIM TO DO IT.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR SHOD WHITE
AGAIN, THE BIGGER ISSUE IS THE
OFFENSIVE ENVIRONMENT, AND
LEONARD FOURNETTE COMING ON
STRONG.
ANY FOURNETTE FANTASY MANAGERS
OUT THERE, YOU PROBABLY
WOULD'VE BEEN BETTER OFF IF
SEASON NOT WATCHING THOSE GAMES
AND NOT GOING THROUGH THE PAIN
ON AND EVERY DRIVE BASIS, BUT
IT'S ONE OF THOSE PLAYERS WE
LOOK UP AT THE END OF THE
SEASON AND MY GOODNESS, TOP 12
RUNNING BACK ON A PER GAME AND
OVERALL BASIS IN FULL PPR
SCORING.
THAT HAS BEEN THE ALLURE FOR
FOURNETTE OR WERE SHOD WHITE
THIS SEASON.
IF YOU ONLY FEATURE ONE OF
THEM, WE ARE IN AN OFFENSE THAT
THERE IS ABOUT TO THOSE RUNNING
BACKS MORE THAN ANYONE OUTSIDE
OF THE LOS ANGELES CHARGERS
UNFORTUNATELY FOR SHOD WHITE,
THAT GUY RIGHT NOW IS LEONARD
FOURNETTE.
IT REALLY ISN'T AS BIG OF A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO
EFFICIENCY LIES. THAT'S WHAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE MAKE IT OUT TO
BE.
WHEN WE LOOK AT POLLARD OR
DAVID MONTGOMERY OR DAVID
HERBERT, YOU LOOK AT THE YARDS
PER CARRY INTO METRICS LIKE
THAT AND ALL OF A SUDDEN IT'S
LIKE WHY ISN'T THE BACKUP
GETTING OUT THERE MORE.
HE IS JUST KILLING IT.
NEITHER OF THESE TAMPA BAY
RUNNING BACKS ARE AVERAGING
OVER FOUR YARDS PER CARRY.
WE ROUTINELY SEE FOURNETTE THE
GREAT IN PASS PROTECTION, EVEN
GOING BACK ALL THE WAY TO WEEK
ONE WHEN HE SENT MICHAEL
PARSONS STRAIGHT TO HECK AND
JUST YARDS PER ROUTE RUN,
SOMETHING THAT FOURNETTE LEADS
IN.
FOR SHOD WHITE HAS ALWAYS BEEN
ONE OF THE TOP HANDCUFFS AND
FANTASY.
WE EVEN SAW HIM CARVE OUT A
NICE LITTLE 50-50 ROLE FOR A
WHILE.
ALL SIGNS POINT TO FOURNETTE
DOWN THE STRETCH, SO I WANT
NOTHING TO DO WITH WHITE.
ALL RIGHT CHAT, RUTGER LOST
TUA, I'M GOING TO HAVE TO BE
WRITING WITH MIKE WHITE.
I LIKE THE IDEA OF HIM TAKING
OVER FOR THE JETS IN THE LONG-
TERM  HIM A LITTLE BIT
OVERBLOWN, BUT THE ONLY THING
WITH BROCK PURDY, YES HE HAS
MULTIPLE TOUCHDOWN PASSES AND
ALL FOUR OF HIS APPEARANCES,
BUT WE'VE SEEN THE SHANAHAN
OFFENSE AT WHAT THEY WANT TO
DO.
THAT'S RUN THE BALL AND GET THE
BALL IN THE HANDS OF THEIR
PLAYMAKERS.
I DON'T THINK HE HAS THE SAME
SORT OF  40, 45 PASS ATTEMPT
UPSIDE THAT SOMEONE LIKE MIKE
WHITE DOES.
WITH THE JETS I UNDERSTAND THAT
IS NOT EXACTLY A LAYUP MATCHUP
AGAINST THE SEAHAWKS TEAM STILL
FIGHTING FOR THEIR FIGHT
AWFULLY MAKE THE PLAYOFFS, BUT
THAT SAID, NOT A SECONDARY THAT
I'M ABSOLUTELY TERRIFIED OF.
THE NUMBER ONE QUARTERBACK
DOESN'T SHATTER.
TWO GUYS I WOULD RECOMMEND
STARTING THIS WEEK.
AND FROM TINSELTOWN, HASKINS OR
D'ONTA FOREMAN.
THAT'S A PRETTY TOUGH ONE.
YOU GUYS ARE GETTING ME TOUGH
STARTS TODAY GETS CHAMPIONSHIP
WEEK.
ISN'T THAT WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT?
I HAVE FOREMAN AS MY RB 26
RIGHT NOW, AND HONESTLY RIGHT
NEXT TO HIM IS GOING TO BE
HASSAN HASKINS.
MONEY IT'S BREAKING DOWN THIS
WAY BECAUSE HASKINS IS
BASICALLY THIS YEAR'S D'ONTA
FOREMAN.
FOREMAN LAST YEAR WAS TAKING
OVER MOST OF THE WORK WHEN
DERRICK HENRY GOT INJURED IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
I'M GOING TO LEAN  TOWARDS
D'ONTA FOREMAN.
AS NICE OF A REPORT AS IT WAS
THAT WE ARE GOING TO SEE A BIG
ROLE FORCED ON HASKINS, STILL A
BIT OF A GUESSING GAME.
I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED AT ALL
IF JULIAN CHESTNUT WOULD BE
HEAVILY INVOLVED.
AND THE SITUATION IN TENNESSEE
COULD BE ABSOLUTELY DISMAL.
THEY ARE PROJECTING THIS
OFFENSE TO SCORE A WEEK LOW AND
IMPLIED POINTS.
I WILL TAKE D'ONTA FOREMAN IN A
PANTHERS OFFENSE THAT HAS BEEN
WITH THE CENTER GUYS EASILY THE
MOST RUN HEAVY GROUP IN THE
LEAGUE.
I'M MORE CONFIDENT OF FOREMAN
GETTING OVER 15 TOUCHES, AND I
THINK THE PANTHERS OFFENSE AS A
WHOLE IS SET UP BETTER THAN THE
TITANS THIS WEEK.
MOVING ONTO SOME WIDE RECEIVERS
AND TIGHT ENDS BEFORE WE GET TO
ALL OF YOUR QUESTIONS.
AGAIN KEEP SENDING THOSE IN THE
CHAT.
JAKE LONDON, SOMEBODY WE AREN'T
TOO HAPPY ABOUT TO START THE
SEASON WITH, HE'S NOT GOING TO
BE A RECOMMENDED START FOR ME
WHEN IT MATTERS MOST.
WE'VE GONE FOUR GAMES WITHOUT
KYLE PITTS IN THE FOLD.
THE FIRST ONE WAS A DUD, A WIDE
RECEIVER 76 FINISHED FOR LONDON
IN FULL PPR SCORING BUT SINCE
THEN WIDE RECEIVER 20, WIDE
RECEIVER 26 AND WIDE RECEIVER
14, ACTUALLY WITH GOOD TARGET
VOLUME.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THESE FOUR
TARGET GAMES WERE HE MADE THE
MOST OUT OF IT.
12, 11, AND NINE TARGETS FOR
LONDON.
THERE HAVE NOT BEEN MANY READ
ANY GUYS THAT WE COULD HAVE ANY
SORT OF HAS CAME EFFICIENCY OR
CONSISTENCY I SHOULD SAY GOING
ON IN ATLANTA THIS YEAR.
DRAKE LONDON BETTER LATE THAN
NEVER STARTING TO GET THEM WITH
DESMOND RITTER UNDER CENTER.
WITH LONDON, ZERO GAMES WITH
EVEN 50+ RECEIVING YARDS AND
WEEKS FOUR THROUGH 12.
I GET IT.
MAYBE HE'S NOT EVEN IN A
POSITION TO HELP SAVE YOUR NON-
CHAMPIONSHIP SQUAD IN THE FIRST
PLACE, BUT THAT SAID, IF YOU DO
HAVE DRAKE LONDON, HE IS MY
WIDE RECEIVER 27 ON THE WEEK
AHEAD OF GUYS LIKE DeANDRE
JOHNSON AND MORE.
ALSO ANOTHER START I'M GOING TO
HAVE HERE IS GOING TO BE NOAH
PHAM OF THE SEATTLE SEAHAWKS,
NOW THAT THE BIG-TIME PAYCHECK
AND OFF-SEASON PITCH A IS ON IR
TO END THE SEASON.
FORMER FIRST ROUND TIGHT END.
YOU CAN SEE WITH A NICE LITTLE
SUN GLASSES RIGHT HERE, GUY IS
ROCKING THE VISOR AND HAS SWAG.
HE CAN MAKE BIG PLAYS AFTER THE
CATCH WHAT SHE'S GOING TO DO
MORE THAN EVER AGAINST THE JETS
DEFENSE THAT ARGUABLY HAS THE
TWO BEST PAIRS OF OUTSIDE
QUARTERBACKS IN THE ENTIRE
LEAGUE.
WHILE DK METCALF, AND IF HE
PLAYS TYLER BALL, HE COULD HAVE
A TOUGH TIMES WITH THOSE
QUARTERBACKS, I THINK TRAN20
CAN BE LEANED ON BECAUSE OF
WELL-BEING OUT AND BECAUSE THIS
IS THE EASIEST WAY TO ATTACK A
VERY STOUT JETS SECONDARY.
MAYBE GINO SMITH RISES TO THE
OCCASION AND THAT REVENGE GAME.
NOAH FANT IS MY TOP RECOMMENDED
ADD ON THE WAY TO WIRE  GO SURE
OF THAT TIGHT END SPOT.
I WOULD START NOAH FANT AHEAD
OF GUYS LIKE HILL , DARREN
WALLER, AND GERALD EVERETT.
A COUPLE MORE CHAT QUESTIONS
BEFORE WE FINISH THINGS OUT
HERE.
ANDREW BRADBURN NEEDS TO START
WHAT YOU DOING PUTTING EKELER
-- YOU NEED TO START BETWEEN
MILES SANDERS, DAVID
MONTGOMERY, OR CAM AKERS.
THAT'S A DECENT QUESTION.
I'M GOING TO GO WITH DAVID
MONTGOMERY.
WE SAW THIS  RUN DEFENSE REALLY
IMPROVE A LOT DURING THE SECOND
HALF OF THE SEASON UNTIL THE LF
320 RUSHING YARDS TO CAROLINA
PANTHERS.
WITH DAVID MONTGOMERY, EVEN
WITH KHALIL HERBERT BACK, EVEN
WHEN KHALIL HERBERT WAS BACK
EARLIER IN THE YEAR, THE BEARS
OFFEND A WAY TO GET THEM OVER
15 TOUCHES AND ALL BUT ONE GAME
THIS SEASON.
BEARS-LYONS HAS THE HIGHEST
COMBINED TOTAL ON THE WEEK.
WHILE JUSTIN FIELDS AND KHALIL
HERBERT ARE ALSO THREATS TO
TAKE SOME OF THAT SHARE IN THE
RUSSIAN GAME, DAVID MONTGOMERY
CONTINUES TO BE THAT WORKHORSE
IN CHICAGO.
VERSUS THOSE OTHER TWO, GIVE ME
DAVID MONTGOMERY, AND YES,
AWESOME.
COLIN FUREY, DJ MOORE, OR TYLER
BOYD IN FULL PPR.
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO GO WITH DJ
MOORE.
I KNOW WE WERE TALKING BOUT HIM
A LITTLE BIT EARLIER, AND JUST
NOT HAVING AS MUCH VOLUME MY
BUT YOU HAVE TO GIVE CREDIT
WHERE CREDIT IS DUE.
DONALD HAS BEEN GOOD AT
TARGETING DJ MOORE THIS YEAR.
WE'VE ACTUALLY GOTTEN THREE
USABLE TOP 24 PERFORMANCES OUT
OF THESE FOUR GAMES HE'S BEEN
UNDER CENTER.
THERE IS A LOW FLOOR, TRULY A
ZERO POINT FLOOR FOR ANYBODY
INVOLVED IN THIS PANTHERS
PASSING GAME.
COMPARED TO GRADE DOSAGE, IT'S
NOT WHO KNOWS WHAT KIND OF
MOTIVATION THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE IN WEEK 17, AND TYLER BOYD
IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE THE
NUMBER THREE OPTION IN THAT
PASSING GAME WITH JASON
HIGGINS.
GIVE ME DJ MOORE.
ALL RIGHT GUYS, TWO MORE SETS
TO GO OVER, AND THEN WE GET TO
ALL YOUR QUESTIONS.
MICHAEL PITTMAN, INDIANAPOLIS
COLTS WILL BE A RECOMMENDED SIT
FOR ME THIS WEEK.
WAS NOT PRETTY, BUT HONESTLY
THIS PASSING GAME IN THE SEASON
AS A WHOLE HASN'T BEEN READY
FOR MICHAEL PITTMAN.
SINCE WEEK ONE, JUST ONE
TOUCHDOWN.
ONE FREAKING TOUCHDOWN SINCE
WEEK ONE.
REMINDER IT'S WEEK 17 RIGHT
NOW.
THAT IS OBJECTIVELY NOT GOOD.
HE'S ONLY UPLAND GAME WITH MORE
THAN 75 RECEIVING YARDS SINCE
WEEK ONE AS WELL.
LOOK AT THAT COLTS OFFENSE.
JONATHAN TAYLOR GOES FOR 160.
HOW TIMES HAVE CHANGED.
LET'S NOT EVEN GET INTO MATT
RYAN.
WE DID SEE PITTMAN HAVE A TEAM-
HIGH SEVEN TARGETS WITH FALLS
UNDER CENTER, BUT I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT YOU GUYS, I WOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED AT ALL OF JEFF
SATURDAY MAKES THAT SWITCH TO
SAM MELLINGER SOONER THAN
LATER, THAT COULD BE A WORSE
OFFENSIVE ENVIRONMENT FOR SAM
PITTMAN.
MAYBE HE DOES GET ONE OF THOSE
WHILE YOU GAME.
WE SAW ON THAT CRAZING VIKINGS
MATCH, YOU WILL TAKE.
ALL THESE START SETS ARE
RELATIVE IF IT IS PITTMAN
VERSUS I DON'T MEAN TO KEEP
TRASHING TUTU ATWELL BUT
SOMEONE LIKE THAT AND YES I
WILL BE TAKING MICHAEL PITTMAN.
OVERALL IN THE WEEK JUST MY
WIDE RECEIVER 29, I'D START
GUYS LIKE DJ MOORE,  JERRY
JEUDY, AND MANY MORE AHEAD OF
HIM.
AND LET'S CLOSE OUT MY TOP 10
STARTS AND SITS WITH RAIDERS
TIGHT END DARREN WALLER.
I HAD HIM ON THIS LIST EVEN
BEFORE FIGHTING AT THE NEWS
ABOUT DEREK CARR, MOSTLY
BECAUSE OF THAT VOLUME ISSUE.
IF YOU ACTUALLY LOOK PAST HIS
TWO DECENT PERFORMANCES BACK
FROM INJURY, HE'S NOT RUNNING A
VAT ON 60% OF THE OFFENSES
DROPPED BACKS.
THEY ARE CLEARLY TRYING TO
EASING BACK INTO ACTION.
WITH THEM BEING PRETTY MUCH
NOTHING TO PLAY FOR OVER THE
PAST TWO WEEKS, TECHNICALLY A
1% CHANCE OF THEM MAKING THE
PLAYOFFS, BUT I THINK WE KNOW
THE RAIDERS AREN'T ANTICIPATING
THAT HAPPENING BY BENCHING
DEREK CARR IN THE FIRST PLACE.
DARREN WALLER IS A COUPLE ENTRY
PASS GAME OPTION IN A PASSING
GAME THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT
BEING DOWNRIGHT TERRIBLE WITH
JARED STIDHAM UNDER CENTER.
MOELLER, BUT FIND TYLER HIGBEE
AND MANY MORE.
AND WITH THAT EVERYONE, LET'S
JUMP INTO PERSONALIZED FANTASY
ADVICE PRESENTED BY STATE FARM
WHERE THE PERSONAL PRICE PLAN
IS ALL ABOUT CREATING A PRICE
JUST FOR YOU.
SEND IN THE START SETS.
IT'S A GREAT DAY TO BE GREAT.
I JUST WANT TO HELP YOU GUYS
WIN THESE FANTASY
CHAMPIONSHIPS.
TYLER HIGBEE OR COMMIT IN HALF-
POINT PPR.
I HAVE TO GO A TYLER HIGBEE.
THE PROBLEMS WE'VE SEEN WITH
TYLER HIGBEE THIS SEASON HAVE
BEEN WHEN THE RAMS HAVE USED
HIM MORE AS A SIXTH OFFENSIVE
LINEMAN AND KEPT HIM IN THE PAST
LOCKE.
SINCE BAKER MAYFIELD HAS BEEN
UNDER CENTER, HIS SEPARATES HER
BACK TO TOUCHING ALMOST 100%.
GIVE ME HIGBEE.
MAN, I'M GOING TO HAVE TO GO
WITH CAM AKERS IN THIS.
IT'S A WILD TIME TO BE ALIVE,
BUT FIRST OF ALL WE HAVE CAMARA
MISSING PRACTICE WITH A QUAD
AND PERSONAL REASONS.
AND EVEN HE IS WONDERING WHY
HE'S NOT BEING USED MORE SO ON
THIRD DOWN, SO AT THIS POINT,
ALVIN KAMARA MANAGING CAREER
LOW MARKS FROM PURELY
PERCEIVING RECEIVING
PRODUCTION.
MEANWHILE CAM AKERS WITH A SNAP
RATE NORTH OF 70% IN HIT THREE
OF HIS LAST FOUR GAMES.
HAD A TEAR FOR MAKING THE
CHAMPIONSHIPS.
HE SEEMINGLY ASKED ME THIS
QUESTION WITH CAM AKERS AND
ALVIN KAMARA ON THE SQUAD.
GIVE ME CAM AKERS ON THIS ONE.
MOST LIKELY TO HAVE HISTORICAL
FANTASY PERFORMANCE.
THIS IS A GOOD ONE.
I ACTUALLY TOOK SOME TIME  TO
GO THROUGH SOME OF THE MOST
MEMORABLE FANTASY PERFORMANCES
AND TWEETED OUT HERE EARLIER.
REMEMBER FROM 2010 TO 2020, WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE 18 WEEK SEASON
YET.
I TOOK THE WEEK 16 PERFORMANCES
FROM THEM INTO WEEK 17 FROM
LAST YEAR, AND MY GOD WE HAD
THE SIX TOUCHDOWN GAME FROM
ALVIN KAMARA WHEN HE WAS
LETTING US ALL KNOW IN 2020.
JAMAR CHASE GOING NUCLEAR LAST
SEASON AND BEFORE THAT , GURLEY
THELEN, ABC QUAN, AND EVEN MR.
THROW UP THE X HIMSELF DEZ
BRYANT GOING ALL THE WAY BACK
IN 2012.
MOST LIKELY JUST A BOOM IN THIS
ONE.
IF YOU LOOK IT HAS TO GO TO
THAT LIONS-BEARS GAME
SOMEWHERE, BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
THAT HIGHEST GAME TOTAL OF THE
WEEK OKAY LIONS DEFENSE THAT
HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO STOP ANYONE
ALL SEASON LONG, AND A BEARS
DEFENSE THAT WASN'T ALL THAT
GREAT TO START THE YEAR, AND
THEY SOLD THERE ONLY TO GOOD
PLAYERS.
I'M GOING TO GO WITH THE SUN
GOD HIMSELF, AMON-RA ST. BROWN
. WE WILL SAY 10 CATCHES, 125
YARDS, NOT ONE BUT TWO
TOUCHDOWNS, GO GET THEM SUN
GOD.
FROM G CLIPS, JARED GOFF, OR
DAK PRESCOTT.
I'M LEANING JUST SLIGHTLY
TOWARDS JARED GOFF.
SOMEONE THAT WE'VE SEEN, GIVE
US HONESTLY GREAT PERFORMANCES
PARTICULARLY IN DOMES.
THAT'S THE WILD PART WITH JARED
GOFF.
I WAS LOOKING THROUGH THESE
STATS.
KUDOS TO THE MAN LAST WEEK,
THREE TOUCHDOWNS TO SHANE'S ALL
STRUGGLING AGAINST THE PANTHERS
OUTDOORS.
IN DOMES WITH THE LIENS OF THE
PAST TWO SEASONS, 35 TOUCHDOWNS
VERSUS 10 PICKS.
OUTDOORS, 10 TOUCHDOWNS VERSUS
THREE PICKS.
I UNDERSTAND HE IS PLAYING MORE
GAMES  INDOORS, BUT THE PASSING
GRADE GOES UP BY 12 POINTS.
YARDS PER ATTEMPT IS HIGHER.
MORE ACCURATE, HIGHER PASSING
RATING.
JARED GOFF IN DOMES IS HARD TO
COMPETE WITH ESPECIALLY WHEN
FACING THE AFRO MENTIONED BEARS
DEFENSE THAT HASN'T BEEN ABLE
TO STOP ANYONE FOR THE BETTER
HALF OF THE SECOND HALF OF THE
SEASON.
JOSH JACOBS OR JARED McKINNON,
A GOOD PROBLEM TO HAVE.
IT'S GOING TO BE JOSH JACOBS.
STILL VERY MUCH LEADS THE NFL
IN RUSHING AND HAS A CAREER
HIGH MARK IN RECEIVING YARDS IN
HIS OWN RIGHT THIS SEASON.
I KNOW McKINNON HAS BEEN
CRUSHING IT, BUT AS WE SAW LAST
WEEK, VERY MUCH SO A TWO
RUNNING BACK BACKFIELD.
GIVE ME THE TRUE WORKHORSE AND
JOSH JACOBS.
FROM REMAKES 84, SINGLE TERRY
OR JAMES COOK.
IT'S GOING TO BE HARRIS FOR ME.
IT COMES DOWN TO THAT SWEET
VOLUME WITH SINGLE TERRY AND
JAMES COOK.
WE SEE THEM NOT CANCEL EACH
OTHER OUT BUT LET'S FACE IT
THAT CHICAGO BEARS GAME, NOT
EXACTLY SEEING THE BILLS ATTACK
DEFENSES IN THAT MANNER.
MEANWHILE HARRIS, THE STEELERS
HISTORICALLY ALL TOO WILLING TO
FEED THERE ARE B1 WHOEVER IT IS
20+ TOUCHES.
GIVE ME HARRIS.
FROM SPORTS WHIZ, GOD OR I'LL
GET THE FLEX.
AS LONG AS DEEBO SAMUEL STAYS
OUT, WHICH IT LOOKS LIKE
ANOTHER WEEK THERE, I WILL
CONTINUE TO GO WITH BRADEN.
DALLAS GODDARD VERY GOOD IN HIS
OWN RIGHT, BUT I'LL KISS THE
TOP 20 WIDE RECEIVER.
FROM IT'S THE MOST, CHURCH OR
JARED GOFF.
CREDIT TO KIRK COUSINS.
THREE STRAIGHT TOP FIVE FANTASY
FINISHES COMING OFF STRONG, BUT
GOING UP IN LIMBO AGAINST A
PACKERS DEFENSE THAT HAS GIVEN
THEM A FEW PROBLEMS OVER THE
YEARS SIMILAR TO JARED GOFF.
WE HAVE SEEN THE BEST VERSION
OF COUSINS INDOORS COMPARED TO
OUTDOORS.
GIVE ME COUGH AND WHAT IS
SHAPING UP TO BE THE SHOOT OUT
OF THE WEEK AGAINST THE BEARS.
FROM B GARCIA, EVANS OR ROMEO
DOBBS.
WILL BE A LITTLE MORE
INTERESTING IF WE DO ACTUALLY
SEE CHRISTIAN WATSON GET RULED
OUT.
I DO SEE HE GOT IN A LIMITED
PRACTICE WITH THAT HIP INJURY
ON THURSDAY.
WITH THAT IN MIND, THAT
OFFENSE, THEY ARE ROTATING GUYS
, SO IF WE HAD A FULL ROLE AND
KNEW EXACTLY THAT ROMEO DOBBS
WOULD BE A NUMBER ONE GUY, I
THINK IT COULD BE A REASONABLY
CLOSE QUESTION.
FOR NOW GIVE ME MIKE EVANS.
IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS WHERE IT
IS WEIRD TO HYPE UP A GUY
TALKING ABOUT THE LACK OF
SUCCESS HE'S HAD OR WHATEVER,
BUT TRULY, 11 STRAIGHT GAMES
WITHOUT A TOUCHDOWN FOR MIKE
EVANS.
HAS ANYONE EVER BEEN MORE DUE
FOR THIS GUY.
MAYBE HE'S WAITING FOR WEEK 17
TO SAVE HIS BEST FOR LAST FOR
ALL THE FAITHFUL FANTASY
MANAGERS STILL SOMEHOW ALIVE
WITH HIM ON THE SQUAD.
FROM NATHAN, INGRAM OR DALTON
SCHOLZ.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION MY
FRIEND.
LET ME PULL UP MY HANDY DANDY
RANKS FROM PFF.COM.
I AM BARELY LEANING TOWARDS
DALTON SCHOLZ.
MY THING WITH THIS, WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE COWBOYS OFFENSE,
ESPECIALLY NOW WITHOUT TONY
POLLARD, IT DOES SEEM LIKE THEY
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO THROW THE
BALL TO HAVE SUCCESS AGAINST
THE TITANS.
IT'S THE TITANS IT'S THE
RAVENS, AND WHO IS THE OTHER
MOSTLY PASS FUNNELED DEFENSE.
TITANS, RAVENS, TWO OF THEM.
TENNESSEE HAS WE'VE SEEN, SO
GOOD AGAINST THE RUN.
THEY FORCE THE OFFENSE TO THROW
THE BALL.
FANTASTIC AT GETTING THAT
VOLUME WEEK IN AND WEEK OUT.
THIS SHOULD BE MORE THAN EVER
AGAIN WITHOUT TONY POLLARD ALSO
OPERATING IN THIS UNDERNEATH
THAT INTERMEDIATE AREAS OF THE
FIELD.
GIVE ME DALTON SCHULTZ BY A
HAIR.
HOUSTON I KNOW  THEY HAVEN'T
EXACTLY BEEN A GOOD TEAM THIS
YEAR.
THEY PLAYED SOME TEAMS MORE
COMPETITIVELY HERE OF THE PAST
THREE WEEKS.
HOUSTON REALLY MUCH BETTER
AGAINST THE PASS AND THE RUN
OVERALL.
FROM SLK 22, START BETWEEN
KRISTA LABBE, ZACH MAAS, AND
BAM NIGHT.
I LEAN TOWARDS THE RUNNING
BACKS IN THAT OCCASION.
ALSO FACING A SEAHAWKS DEFENSE
BOTTOM FIVE AGAINST THE
POSITION IN PPR POINTS PER
GAME, AND THEN WITH ZACH ROSS
WE ARE ALSO LOOKING AT 20+
TOUCHES.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THE GAME SCRIPT, BUT HE DID
HAVE OVER 70% OF THE OFFENSIVE
SNAPS LAST WEEK.
OBVIOUSLY THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO
STAY SUPER REPETITIVE.
MAAS IS ON THE TABLE.
AND FROM OCCASIONALLY THESE
GUYS ARE BACK INTO ACTION EVEN
AFTER THEY ARE BACK FROM
HAMSTRING OR CONDUCTION.
NOT ENTIRELY SURE HOW HEALTHY
HE IS EVEN THE TWO RUNNING
BACK'S THAT I AM CONFIDENT IN
THEIR OVERALL VOLUMES.
SANDERS AND FOURNETTE, IF IT'S
STANDARD SCORING, THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN WE COULD GO WITH CAM
AKERS AND SANDERS, BUT
OTHERWISE GIVE ME LEONARD
FOURNETTE.
THIS  SHOCKED ME AS SOMEONE WHO
IS SEEING LEONARD FOURNETTE THE
TOP 12 RUNNING BACK IN FULL PPR
NOT ONLY OVERALL BUT ALSO ON A
PER GAME BASIS.
A WILD TIME TO BE ALIVE.
THEN WITH CAM AKERS, BILLY
HAVING MORE, HE IS HAVING A
FEATURED ROLE NOW THAT WE
THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO HAVE TO
START THE SEASON.
I GET IT.
FIRST 12 WEEKS ABSOLUTELY
TERRIBLE TIME TO BE IN THE CAM
AKERS BUSINESS.
THINGS HAVE STARTED TO TURN
AROUND FOR BOTH HIM AND THE
RAMS OFFENSE EVER SINCE BAKER
MAYFIELD GOT THERE.
SHOULD I START PATTERSON OR AJ
DYLAN.
IT HAS TO BE AJ DYLAN.
IT PAINS ME AGAIN.
LONG TIME PRESIDENT OF THE
PATTERSON FAN CLUB, BUT HE HAS
BEEN ON THE CHART BY TYLER
ALLGEIER.
AVERY WILSON IS GETTING MORE
TARGETS THAN CORDERO PATTERSON.
I DON'T GET IT BUT IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHAT I GET.
YOU JUST HAVE TO READ THE USAGE
AND GO FROM THERE.
GIVE ME AJ DYLAN.
FROM TRENT HAMMOND, TYLER BOYD
OR JACOBY MYERS.
THAT'S A TOUGH ONE.
IF WE SEE DeVANTE PARKER GET
BACK FROM THE PATRIOTS, I'M
GOING TO LEAD TOWARDS TYLER
BOYD.
JUST THE OVERALL PASSING
ENVIRONMENT I WANT TO SAY THAT
HE'S LED THEM TO OVER THE PAST
10 WEEKS.
I HAVE BEEN'S WORD JACOBY MYERS
HAS BEEN GETTING FED TARGETS
AND EVERYTHING, BUT THERE WERE
WEEKS WHERE IT HAS BEEN
KENDRICK BORN.
NELSON AGHOLOR HAS HAD A GOOD
GAME OVER THE PAST FEW WEEKS.
A BIT TOO CROWDED FOR ME IN AN
OFFICE IT DOESN'T HAVE ALL THAT
MUCH OFFSIDE IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
GIVE ME A GUY AT LEAST IN AN
OFFENSIVE BY JOE BURROW AND
THEN YOU CAN WRAP YOUR MIND
AROUND HAVING A TRUE BOOM
PERFORMANCE.
STONY, I WILL BE GOING WITH
AIYUK IN THAT GROUP.
WITHOUT DEEBO SAMUEL, I KNOW
THE LAST TWO WEEKS HAS BEEN
GEORGE KITTLE GETTING THE MULTI-
TOUCHDOWN GAMES AND ALL OF
THAT, BUT WE'VE SEEN IT HAPPEN
IN OFFENSES LIKE THE  EAGLES
FOR EXAMPLE, ESPECIALLY EARLIER
IN THE YEAR WERE A.J.
BROWN, DeVANTE SMITH, DALLAS
GODDARD, IT'S TOUGH FOR A RUN
FIRST OFFENSE TO KEEP ALL THREE
OF THE REALLY TALENTED PASS
CATCHERS PUTTING UP
CONSISTENTLY HIGH AND
PRODUCTION WEEK IN AND WEEK
OUT.
AGAIN IF YOU JUST SIT BACK A
LITTLE BIT AND CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT AIYUK AS THE FUTURE WIPER
RECEIVER IN AN OFFICE THAT HAS
BEEN ABLE TO ROUTINELY  RAYS
PAST AT 30 POINT MARK EVEN WITH
BROCK PURDY UNDER CENTER, I
WILL TAKE  AIYUK.
FINALLY WE HAVE DeVANTE ADAMS ,
AIYUK, AND I DON'T WANT TO BE A
COMPLETE  SLAVE, BUT IT'S
DeVANTE ADAMS.
START YOUR STUDS.
THERE MIGHT NOT BE A MORE
STEADY WIDE RECEIVER IN THE NFL
THEN DAVANTE ADAMS.
IT'S ROUGH AND JARED STIDHAM
UNDER CENTER.
ADAMS HAS BEEN SLAPPING
RELATIVES OVER THE PAST THREE
WEEKS, BUT IF THERE IS EVER A
TIME FOR THE RAIDERS TO FORCE-
FEED THE GUY HE WAS COMPLAINING
OUT ABOUT GETTING BENCHED IN
THE FIRST PLACE, YOU WOULD
THINK IT WOULD BE IN THIS SPOT.
WITH DAVANTE ADAMS, EVEN IF THE
EFFICIENCY IS DOWN COMPARED TO
GUYS LIKE AIYUK AND DJ, WE
COULD BE TALKING ABOUT HIM
HAVING HONESTLY DOUBLED THE
AMOUNT OF TARGETS AT THOSE GUYS
ARE GOING TO SEE.
THAT'S GOING TO WRAP UP ANOTHER
EDITION OF  BR THAT